dans cette enseigne basée à coignières
des revêtements pour le sol des
aménagements pour la salle de bains mais
aussi depuis peu des solutions
hydro-alcooliques un produit devenu
indispensable face à la situation
sanitaire que l'entreprise a eu
l'autorisation de fabriquer notre
fabricant français qui est hydro
minérale et il a eu l'autorisation
dernièrement et il s'est très vite
adapté il a eu l'autorisation de
transformer sa production s'est produit
on les a déjà dans un premier temps
j'irais proposer à notre clientèle
traditionnelle c'est-à-dire aux
entreprises du bâtiment qui ont en ont
besoin aussi à tous nos futurs confrères
commerçants de la zone de coignières de
rambouillet et de saint quentin en
yvelines et on dirait prochainement nous
proposons ce même produit aux
particuliers suivant les besoins
le conditionnement de 5 et 20 litres
permet en plus du lavage des mains de
prévoir une désinfection du mobilier des
locaux cette adaptation de l'entreprise
lui a notamment permis de conserver une
activité plus soutenue alors que l'accès
au magasin était uniquement réservé aux
professionnels
aujourd'hui seule la moitié des 11
salariés sont en chômage partiel
cette activité de production et
distribution de solutions
hydroalcooliques pourrait se poursuivre
encore quelques temps on arrive à une
situation de façon rapide parce qu'il
faut le faire et on y est
voilà on est dans notre jeu peut être
notre nouveau métier